Transcriber: Nesma Habashy
المدقّق: rana heloun
دعوني أطرح عليكم سؤال قبل أن أبدأ،
من هنا يعرف ما هو علم الفلك؟
جيد عدد مقبول، أبقوا أيديكم مرفوعة،
وهيا نصعب الموضوع قليلًا.
من يعرف أهمية كوكب المشتري
للأرض يبقى يده مرفوعة.
يا ستار يا رب.
كوكب المشترى يُعد من أكبر
كواكب المجموعة الشمسية.
وبسبب حجمه أصبح له جاذبية أقوى
مرتين ونصف من جاذبية الأرض.
تلك الجاذبية أصبحت مثل الشّفّاط الذي يشفط
أي كويكب أو جسم خارجي يقترب من الأرض.
أي أن دونه الحياة على الأرض كانت
من الممكن أن تنتهي قبل أن تبدأ حرفياً.
بمعنى أخر، ما هو أول شيء
خطر في أذهانكم عندما تكلمت عن الفلك.
مؤكد خطر في أذهان ناس كثيرة
موضوع الأبراج وجلب الحبيب وأكل الزبيب،
لكن الموضوع مختلف تماماً.
والفجوة هنا بسبب عدم اهتمام
العرب بمثل هذه العلوم.
فعلم الفلك يعني استكشاف ورصد الكواكب
والنجوم والسدم والمذنبات.
وكلمة الفلك مشتقة من الأفلاك وهي مسارات
دوران الكواكب حول الشمس أو أي نجم أخر.
يستغل المتحدثون عن الأبراج وكشف المستقبل
قلة وعي الناس بادعائهم أنهم علماء في الفلك
لكن الموضوع غير ذلك تماما.
توجد حاليا 72 وكالة فضاء حول العالم،
منها وكالات مدنية تابعة لمنظمات فردية
وأخرى حربية تابعة لمنظمات حكومية.
منها من لديها رواد فضاء ومنها لا، ومنها
لديها أقمار صناعية ومنها لا وإلى أخره.
ما أقصده أن عندما يكون هناك 72 وكالة فضاء
حول العالم وستة منها فقط في دول عربية،
لذا يجب أن نعرف أن هناك شيء خطأ.
إذا نظرنا لهذه الصورة التي توضح النسبة
التي تخصصها الحكومة من دخلها
سنعرف أننا بعيدون جدا.
مؤكد أنني لا أحلم أن الاثنتين وعشرون دولة
عربية يستطيعون عمل وكالة فضاء.
طبيعي، لأن ما زال هناك دول نامية،
لكننا نجد دول غنية كثيرة لديها الإمكانية
الكاملة لعمل وكالة فضاء.
لكنهم ليسوا مهتمين للأسف.
وحتى الدول النامية ممكن أن يشتركوا
لعمل وكالة فضاء مشتركة
مثل وكالة الفضاء الأوروبية؛
التي شراكة بين الدول الأوربية.
أو حتى أن يُدرسوا علم الفلك
في المدارس والجامعات.
قد يقال لي لماذا؟ لماذا يجب الاهتمام
بعلم الفلك واستكشاف الفضاء؟
ألا يجب أن ننتهي من الأرض، أولًا؟
من أخبرك أن علم الفلك واستكشاف الفضاء
ليس مرتبطاً بالأرض؟
بالإضافة لأن استكشاف الفضاء يساعد
في تقدم الدول،
فهو يساعدنا في الوصول للاختراعات العظيمة،
وزيادة النوابغ في تلك المجالات.
إلى جانب استخدام معادن الفضاء
في صناعات كثيرة نحتاج إليها.
دعونا نأخذ مثال حي على أهمية
تدريس علم الفلك في المدارس والجامعات.
هذه وكالة الفضاء المصرية، التي أُسست سنة
2018، وهي وكالة فضاء مدنية،
ليس لديها رواد فضاء،
ولا تُطلق صواريخ استكشافيه لكواكب أخرى.
لكن في المستقبل قد تصنع مصر أقمارها
الصناعية وتطلق صواريخها بنفسها.
وعندما يأتي ذلك الوقت مؤكد ستحتاج مهندسين
وأناس مهتمة بهذا المجال أو تحتاج أجانب،
مما سيقلل نسبة أهمية وكالة الفضاء المصرية.
وسيكون أسهل لنا التصنيع
في دول أجنبية أخرى.
وتبعًا لدراسة علماء كثيرون يمكننا في
المستقبل أن نستكشف كواكب صالحة للسكن.
وممكن أن نستعمرها وهذا سيقلل نسبة الزيادة
السكانية في دول كثيرة أخرى.
وعلى ذكر فرص العمل تعالوا نتكلم على
فرص العمل التي يوفرها مثل هذا العلم.
أولًا يوفر للمهندسين من جميع المجالات
فرص عمل،
حيث يساعد المهندسون في تصميم وبناء الأنظمة
والمركبات الفضائية
باستخدام الرياضيات
والمعرفة التقنية الحديثة.
يبلغ عدد المهندسين في هذا المجال تقريبًا
135 ألف مهندس سنة 2019  فقط.
وفي نفس السنة توفرت فرص عمل لأكثر من
66 ألف مهندس حول العالم.
ثانيًا، يوفر لخبراء العلوم الصحية والطبية
فرص عمل،
فخبراء العلوم الصحية يعطون الدعم السريري
لرواد الفضاء ويهتمون بهم،
كما أنهم يعملون أبحاث على كيفية تأثير
الفضاء على الكائنات الحية.
لكن على عكس المهندسين، عدد الخبراء
في هذا المجال قليل للغاية،
وهذا يبين نسبة أهمية الخبراء في هذا المجال
بمعنى أنه مجال مطلوب.
ثالثًا، يوفر لعلماء الفلك فرص عمل،
فتقدم المجال ككل معتمد عليهم.
علماء الفلك يستكشفون ويطورون النظريات
القائمة في هذا المجال.
إذا نظرنا لدولة مثل كندا التي تمتلك
40 ألف عالم وعالمة في جميع المجالات،
سنجد أن 10 آلاف منهم يعملون في مجال الفلك،
بما يعادل 25 في المئة منهم.
إذا قارنا ذلك بمصر التي لديها 90 ألف
عالم في جميع المجالات،
يعني إذا أخذنا منهم 25 في المائة،
يعني توفر فرص عمل
لأكثر من 22 ألف عالم مصري.
رابعًا، يوفر للتقنيين والفنيين
فرص عمل كثيرة.
فالفنيين والتقنيين يساعدون
في تصميم وبناء وتطوير الأنظمة،
وهذا أكثر مجال يعمل فيه الناس.
خامسًا، يوفر لرواد الفضاء فرص عمل،
رواد الفضاء هم المستكشفين في العصر الحديث،
فهم يسافرون خارج الأرض ليكتشفوا ويطوروا
نظريات في الفضاء.
عدد رواد الفضاء في هذا المجال تقريبا
ستمائة شخص،
والرقم قليل بسبب متطلبات الشغل
الدقيقة والصعبة
مثل وجود خبرة عسكرية والعمل كطيار
طائرات نفاثة لمدة ثلاث سنوات
أو الطيران بطائرات نفاثة لمدة ألف ساعة.
أرأيتم؟
إن الموضوع صعباً،
لكن لن يكون مستحيلاً أبدا.
يوجد شباب كثيرون حول العالم، بدؤوا توجيه
اهتماماتهم للسماء، مثل (أليسا كارسون).
أليسا كارسون، الفتاة ذات التسع عشرة سنة
هي أصغر رائدة فضاء في التاريخ.
تُجهز لتكون في أول رحلة تضم البشر للمريخ،
كما أنها اُختيرت من قبل سبعة سفراء
يمثلون مشروع (مارس ون)،
وهذا المشروع يستهدف استعمار المريخ
بحلول سنة 2030.
أرأيتم أن هناك شباب بالفعل يُفرح وأن
الموضوع ليس مستحيل.
نحتاج فقط أن كل الناس تهتم بعلم الفلك
وتظهر اهتمامها به.
ولماذا ننظر بعيدًا؟
أنا عمري 13 سنة،
وأنشأت تطبيق به خريطة للسماء.
ويُعد أول تطبيق تعليمي
عن الفضاء يدعم اللغة العربية.
وفي هذا العام أخذ المركز الخامس في مسابقة
في (هونغ كونغ) على مستوى العالم.
هيا نأخذ رحلة سريعا داخله.
تلك الشاشة الرئيسية حيثما تُختار اللغة،
إذا اخترنا اللغة العربية، فهذا ما سيظهر،
وهنا خريطة السماء، وما هو علم الفلك،
وما هي ناسا،
ونتيجة السنة في الأحداث الفلكية،
إذا اخترنا خريطة السماء هذا ما سيظهر، فهي
فيها المجموعات الشمسية والمجموعات النجمية،
وفيها شرح للمبتدئين عن علم الفلك.
كما أن بها الصور التاريخية التي رسمها
الإغريق في الماضي عن المجموعات النجمية.
وهذه هي المبادرة التي أحببت أن أشارك فيها
اهتمامي عن علم الفلك،
نحتاج فقط أن كل شخص منا يشارك اهتمامه،
لنقول عن أنفسنا مجتمع مهتم بعلم الفلك،
لأنه ببساطة، الفضاء جوهرة،
لكن للأسف مدفونة في الوحل.